la neige qui se trouve au dessus des épi
l'hiver est arrivé très tôt trop tôt
pour terry drouin le producteurs de
grains de série près de lévis il estime
que le tiers de ces épis de maïs utilisé
pour nourrir ses vaches laitières sera
perdu cette année on a tenté de récolter
cette semaine qui sait on s'est rendu
compte qu on en perdait trop fait le on
espère finalement quel niveau de neige
s'abaisse assez pour réussir à récolter
les épis cas aussi c'est que la neige
accumulée empêche la machinerie de
ramasser les épis ajoutons aussi que la
plupart étaient déjà cassé en raison de
la tempête automnale du 1er novembre
le maïs a été affecté par le vin de
leurs origines plusieurs fusions
seulement à damon ce retard des power
women who et le maillet s'ils étaient
dans le cher puis il s'est fait courser
par le vent même son cloche pour un
autre producteur du coin
il s'agit de l'une des pires saisons de
sa vie à le problème qu'on a eu cette
année c'est qu'on eu un printemps très
pluvieux très froid on était quinze
jours à trois semaines entend avant
demain par brassaï à faire trop froid
avec un automne pluvieux qui nous a pas
aidés les producteurs de grains du
québec estime que 74 % du maïs n'a pas
été récoltés au québec en raison des
caprices de la météo
demande une rencontre d'urgence avec
québec dans les prochains jours afin
d'aider les producteurs essuyé leurs
pertes
on souhaiterait que le gouvernement
le ministre de l'agriculture les
financières mettre en place une cellule
de crise pour bien gérer cette
problématique le ministère de
l'agriculture on assure qu'une rencontre
est prévue prochainement
la pluie verglaçantes annoncées dans les
prochaines heures dans la région
pourrait augmenter le stress des
producteurs te donne aussi un supplément
taurian le si beaucoup de stress et t on
retrouver ses ont voté pour réussir les
revenus sont en fonction de ce que les
producteurs sont plus tendus louvre les
récoltes ne sont pas terminées que les
producteurs se disent déjà tournés vers
2020 ici oubliez l'année 2019 ici félix
morissette beaulieu radio canada québec